[Music]
do you think you could tap out Nick
Jonas yes absolutely under present when
under birth a demi lovato is a force in
the gym and on screen her new YouTube
documentary Demi Lovato simply
complicated is open honest and raw when
I'm comfortable in my own skin
I feel confident you jitsu Demi as my
favorite let's talk about this this love
and have you gotten the black belt yet I
need that update I finally got a blue
belt which was so exciting for me and I
I do have a huge love for Brazilian
jiu-jitsu it's like it's a new passion
of mine passion comes in multiple forms
for the 25 year old singer in the
documentary Demi doesn't hold back from
sharing her love life this is the
longest you've gone without being in a
relationship why do you think he broke
up I loved when you said about will
morale I'll never love anyone like him
and I don't know if I ever can meet
anyone that could compete that was very
inspiring for you to sort of be like I
need to find my own person have you
found her yeah I think I found her and I
think that I'm still finding her and
that's why I'm not diving into anything
with anyone but then seeing all this
footage of you guys I was like I kind of
want them at the end of all this to like
end up back together is that like still
a possibility you never know what's
gonna happen and I don't know it's gonna
happen
[Music]
you